it was seen as an historic agreement
last year germany apologized for
atrocities committed in namibia in the
colonial era between 1904 and 1908
german soldiers killed tens of thousands
of over gerero and nama people in what
became known as the first genocide of
the 20th century as part of last year's
deal berlin also agreed to fund projects
for the groups worth more than 1 billion
euros but descendants of the victims are
unhappy with the agreement they say it's
not enough and were excluded from the
negotiations and now they're urging
germany to change it
well let's discuss this further with
sema laypert she is a namibian activist
and serves on the nama traditional
leaders technical committee on genocide
she's currently in berlin to speak with
the german government about the
reparation deal it's good to have you
with us here on dw news africa could you
first tell us why you're unhappy about
this current agreement
yes um
thank you for having me we are we don't
agree with the agreement because first
of all it has been done without our
participation
also it does not address the crime of
genocide at all
it
is basically a
demand from a former colony from its
former colonial master for development
funding
in lieu of reparations and it uses the
genocide as a smokescreen
to look for this funding
and this is why we don't agree with it
but also
a key deficiency is that it does not
address the needs of those in the
diaspora who went into exile as a result
of this
genocide so
yes
but fundamentally
it does not acknowledge genocide
it does not acknowledge genocide as a
crime
but it is rather
a
maybe constitutes a legitimate claim
from a former
colonial master for the crime of
colonization but it does not address the
crime of genocide
so you're here now to try to persuade
the german government to change the
current deal how far have you gotten
with that
we have requested a meeting particularly
with the foreign office
the foreign minister
frau baibog but she has declined our
invitation
we have been trying to get in touch with
miss baybach for quite some time since
december last year after she was put
into office but until now it has been
very disappointing that she has not made
any attempt
in order to engage directly with us so
yes
unfortunately the german government con
continues to refuse to talk to the nama
and the over hero people
now the namibian government has accepted
this deal 1.3 billion dollars in
development to support your community
but are you saying that
the government doesn't represent
your people in in these talks
yes
the namibian government
does not represent us in these talks
because the genocide was not committed
against the namibian government it was
committed against the nama in the over
hero people the nama and the over hero
people have got the legitimate
representatives in terms also of a
namibian law and so germany has a
responsibility to talk to the
communities against which this genocide
was committed the genocide was not
committed against the namibian
government and therefore namibia the
namibian government has got no legal
authority or even political authority to
speak on our behalf yes the namibian
government has a important role to play
on behalf of its citizens by
facilitating this discussion between the
nama and ovahero people and the and the
german government
but namibia's president has said that he
represents all namibians when it comes
to this issue and some would argue that
perhaps this is politicizing something
that is a domestic problem
mr
mr kangope the president of namibia does
not represent the nama and the over here
people
in this particular discussion
not in general but in this particular
discussion we have never asked him to
represent us
we have the legal successes
of the leaders against whom this
genocide was committed and they are the
ones we have the right to
self-representation and to decide who is
going to speak on our behalf okay and
finally
if you could just paint a picture for us
on clearly this issue sort of resonates
amongst people living in namibia right
now
what are those issues just remind us
again and how far are you prepared to
take this
after the people were put into
concentration camps the german
government passed a number of ordinances
one of them being the expropriation of
land and livestock of our property we
were put into native reserves and we
continue to remain in those native
reserves
the purpose of these native reserves was
to keep us in poverty and this is where
we still remain and germany has got a
responsibility to do something about
this how far are we
willing to take this we are willing to
take both the namibian government to
court for violating our right of self
representation also doing things without
our free prior informed consent okay so
yes simulator thank you very much indeed
for speaking to dw news africa thank you